igen e ez újabb újabb jó téma hog
beszélni a családi értékrendről hogy
egyes emberek ezt miért látják ennyire
fontosnak és ezzel szemben mi mit
gondolunk úgy is lesz egy időszak amikor
a kortársak véleménye fontosabb de azzal
szoktuk szokták biztatni a
pszichológusok a szülőket hogy azért a
megfelelő időben elvetett magok azok
egyszer csak szárba szökkennek sokszor
van egy ilyen apájos vagy nem aszájos
bocsánat időszak amikor szülő úgy érzi
hogy elvesztette a fonalat de azok a
dolgok visszajönnek tehát hogy minden ez
hány éves korba minden szó várható ez a
a a visszajövés nem a az a a azaszájos
időszak hát a ttinédzserkor t 1 éves
kort igen igen igen igen azt szokták
mondani hogy mikor adja a telefon hogy
legyen a gyerek felkészülve legyen a
család felkészülve a gyerek
felkészülésse az például az hogy van-e
felelősségérzete tehát tud-e otthon
például rá lehet-e bízni egyszerű
dolgokat vásárlást nem tudom segítsen
attó fü hogy milyen élethelyzetben él a
másik az hogy hogy tudja az érzelmeit
menedzselni hogyha ugye minden gyerek
máskor érik tanítsuk meg előbb a
gyereket arra hogy a maga életkori
sajátosságainak megfelel de tudja
moderálni az
érzelmeit tudjon jól kommunikálni tudjon
bocsánatot kérnie
[Zene]